so when you're in this writing room with
other late night writers is there are
there
certain news sources you go to to look
for stories are they
all on up for grabs um what what is the
process you would normally go through
well i have my typical process is to
i used to go like yahoo was the thing it
always had
nicely written headlines and now it's
all changed because
you'll see cnn and uh every one of the
major outlets except for reuters and ap
every one of those guys are writing
click bait headlines
because they're trying to heighten your
curiosity get you to click the story
and so when you get into that story
you've got to look at the first
couple of paragraphs to find the actual
headline to find the joke
what the what the story is about and so
that's where i think comedians make a
big mistake
they sort of just reprint the headline
and that's not how somebody talks a host
would never
say something like you say a headline
like that they they basically hey did
you guys hear about this like it's a
conversation
and now you have the setup so i would my
sources are mostly um
sometimes cnn new york times uh i go to
like
aggregate sources uh
refdesk.com will often have
so many different sources on there uh
news.google.com
also has so many different sources if i
find a story i like i can click
uh you know you know uh a deeper search
it says
review all it'll show all these news
sources that are writing the same story
and some of them will actually write the
headline that you need
and you go oh that's exactly what i'm
looking for right there it's already
written
um because it's coming from a different
source remember
most of these people are copywriters so
they're taking the main story coming
from ap
wire or reuters and they're rewriting it
for
their you know their rag their their
online source uh also i would go to like
local news channels like you know here
we have ktla morning news or ktla
channel 5 news i'd click them because
now you're listening to people say it
the way it's spoken
rather than the way it's written and a
lot of times listening to cnn in the
morning or something when i first
started
i'd listen to somebody say the line and
sometimes the joke is right there like
uh oahu hawaii today lost power to the
entire island
and this already that's already a setup
you know
um and it was like and then what she did
she almost wrote the joke she goes
traffic lights were out court buildings
were shut down and about a hundred
thousand kids
stayed home from school today now i know
once she says
those two three ideas i can eliminate
one and just do a three-way build-up
she already wrote the joke for me you
know oahu who i lost power to the entire
island traffic lights were out core
buildings were shut down
and a vacationing don king was seen with
flat hair
so because there's no electricity now
you have a joke that's suitable for
the tonight show it's not great for
stand up i wouldn't do it in stand-up
club i'd do it for the tonight show
because that's a different little
late show audiences are a little
different so that's kind of how
i would do it and i you know i have i
still have a process i still sit down
and write
uh jokes every day you know on current
events
if you're serious about becoming a
comedian join our facebook group
linked in the description below to start
getting tips like these
every single day and watch this playlist
of our top writing tips to improve your
writing
today